το θέματα ότι για κάποιος μήναι σε σταματήσανταάλκοτες ενα θερες που ποτε ούτε ελέγχους ούτε
τίποτε με στο δρόμο γιατί ενα εχει ελευτά να πληρώθειό να τν λιγώσω και ακόμα
είναι σηλευτά πληρωτία στνομικς γιατί να πλέρο τους ακόμα στυνομικός ευκαλαν των νεων προπολογισμό ελλεία
τα λεφτά χρειάζονται παραπάνω λευτά γιατί δεν είναι μόνο ποσοτικό α ήτον αφέρω αστυνομικούς πολλούς
ενα έναγκεφαλειο τον αούμε χόμως και ους αστυνομικούς τους έμπιρου αμε για να μπορέσουν να
βοηθήσουν να γίναι αυτόν το κράμμα να αποδώσει χρειάζομε ελεφτά χρειάζουμε ελεφτά να αποδώσουν επιπρόσσετα
καθήκντα επιπρσθετες περιβολίες επιπρόσθετες γερευνήσεις διαρευνήσεις πολλασμαμικών κεβαλεο του θα ούλλα χρειάσουν τελευτά ναι η
αστυνομία εχεί τρακό εκατομύρια μόνον στους μισθούς σε αυτά απου πρέπει τα επολύμε αβδομήντα μόνο
για τον εξοπλισμό και ένα κράτος ο ευρωπαρικό που έχι κύρεθυσα θα λασα αστυνομική που
τίνα επιβλέπω νεκρά ζόνι ναι αστνομική πυ είαι επιβλέπω καθημειρίνή παραβατικό το αργονομένο εγκλημένια αστυνομική
όκι στα λιγόπτερα εναία αστυνομική ο ποτεν αντιλιυθεί δι ότι ην πργμαστε τον μονατικών ευρωπαηκών
κράτος το οποίον πεντέμεισε ιγιά στνομικά σχολούνται με τα πάντα σετούνται η δημοκρατία δώστε τους
αυτά που πρέπει πριν να κλίσουμε να γιατί έχει περάσει ώρα να σε ρωτήσω ο
κύπριος πρέα νιώθει ασφαλίς εγώ προσωπικά από καληυκόρα επορτά σε είναι σημέρα να περάσει να
με νααπούσουμε ενεπυροβολή σα σπι τη κάποιο βαλάπόμπαν κάποιου μασελωθήκακάποιοι εκρούσαν τα αυτικεών κάποιου θεωρίσει
ότι πρέα νιώθει ασφαλείς ο κύπριος πολίτης με την αστυνομία που έχει σήμερα τός ο
τόπος έχουμε πιότη ήταν τρομερί όμως πρέπει να γινούν το μές για να μπορέσει να
νιώσε τα ασφάλια πρέπει να δώσουμε νέφαση και βάσει στην καθημερινή παραβατιγό ενιος στο ρογαμένο
έγκλημα και το λέω ίσως πρέπει κάποια τμήατα να ενωθούν γιατί πρέει να αυξήσουμε την
πρόληψηδεν είσευ να στυμεγωσία πλος πολίτης